Before the model is created,
we can use a config method to
configure how it gets set up.
The config method takes a function.
UI router includes
a lot of functionality.
Two components will be using our
state provider and URL provider.
We'll inject both of these
into the config function.
Providers are like services, but
only providers can be used for
a module configuration.
We can now use state provider to set
up the different states of our app.
Let's start out with the default
state and call it home.
To add a state to our app,
we call .state, give the state a name.
Again we're gonnause home, and
give it a configuration object.
With the URL for the state.
The template to use our app is
already using the default template.
So we'll link to that.
And the controller to load for
that template.
Review state provider to
set up a state for the app.
We need to use URL router provider
to load the home state by default.
So the app state
management is all set up.
But there's one last thing,
we need to tell UIRouter where
to insert this template.
We can do that with a directive UIView.
We have access to this directive because
we've included the UIRouter module
into our project.
UI router is now handling
our app's state.
Let's add a new state for
an individual menu item.
Let's create an item state.
We also need to create the template and
controller for this item.
Pay attention to this right here,
the colon id.
We can use dynamic
content in our routing.
Let's quickly generate a template and
a controller for an item.
I've also created a few JSON files with
more details about the menu items.
When the URL is item slash some menu ID.
The ID will be accessible in the either
controller by using the state
param service.
We'll also add in a food finder service,
so that we can retrieve the item.
We'll use the get item function and
lookup the item by its ID.
Then when it's returned the JSON file,
we'll set it to
the item's data property.
The get items function is
very similar to get menu.
Except that it gets a single
item specified by the ID.
Let's make the name a link
to that item's detail page.
UI Router gives us the ui-sref
directive to switch between states.
We want to switch to the item state and
pass along a value.
The state expects an ID which
we'll set to the items ID.
Now it's just filling out
the template for the item.
Let's have it show the item's name,
the image of the menu item, and
its rating and description.
And now our app can be in the default
state with the menu showing, or
it can be in an item state.
How awesome is that?